being that we did have such an
unconventional upbringing
and while that kind of um
freewheeling lifestyle i tended to do
pretty well in
and i think it's another reason why when
i was 15 and i was
you know gonna move to a foreign country
and and work by myself my mom was like
okay go
would i ever let my 15 year old daughter
do that
no like i literally she dropped me off
at the airport and i had a
name this is granted this was in 1995.
so things were very different than we
didn't have cell phones
when she dropped me off the airport i
had the a scrap of paper with a man's
number written on it
we didn't know who this guy was or
someone i was supposed to call when i
got to italy
oh my god and she's like all right love
you and like drives off
you know but but back then it's like she
she was always kind of this
an eccentric artist as well so i think
just the idea of me going and working in
italy she was like go and i think there
was a part of her that knew i'd be okay
this podcast exists because i
love talking to people and i love going
deep the purpose is
to plant seeds of inspiration we
enter a space of vulnerability and
relatability and what you realize
is that we are so much more alike than
we are different
to quote ramdas we're all just walking
each other home
and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense welcome back to
the pretty intense podcast
on the show today is someone that well
basically i just
really want to be best friends with her
her name is laura prepon
you probably know her from that 70s show
or orange is the new black
she's an actor director producer writer
chef and as soon as i started
researching
more about her i was like oh my gosh
i this is going to be so easy she loves
cooking
she loves uh the body and how to take
care of it and
food and inner work and growing as a
person
and you know that was reflected a lot in
her book which is called
you and i as mothers that came out in
2020
she has two kids she's just so extremely
like
strong and driven but yet really open
and vulnerable
and so the conversation gets into
everything from you know
patterning in childhood and the unique
upbringing that she had with her mom and
her dad who were very
you know busy um but absent and the pros
and cons that that
led to in her life and then just her
love for cooking
and the things that she does to ground
and how she wants to take care of her
kids and
of course all the things that are you
know she's working on now that will
inevitably lead into more amazing
accomplishments in her career but
laura's a really cool girl and i think
that uh you'll probably think the same
thing when you get to the end of this
interview so enjoy
it's much easier i mean like there's a
lot about it that's easier
but it's still like i'm it's a block for
me i
don't know i feel like people have two
kinds of brains one
tends to be more artistic or one is a
little bit more mathematical and
when it comes to math it's like it's a
light switch that goes off for me
i don't know if you can relate to that
but i totally can and especially after
this year when we're all trying to do
all these things via zoom
and all this digital stuff it's it's
weird it's weird
yeah i heard yeah look at look at what
we're doing right now
that's true i mean like there was a
phase in the beginning of doing the show
where everything was everybody was in
person and that was so great you
you have a you you get a rapport
because there's that time before and
time after that you normally spend with
them and
you're like wow we're friends and and
when you do it like this it's a little
bit less
but um you know we held back on doing
some interviews for a while just because
we're like oh we'd rather
love to get in person but they just are
so much easier to get like this and so
you know i have you know leggings on
like i'm sure most people do when
they're doing interviews right now like
this didn't take too long because i
didn't have to get like fully ready so
it's cool to be able to do these things
because you're probably are you in new
york
i am i am in new york but what's funny
about what you just said is most
meetings that you do via zoom
nobody's wearing the matching pants or
skirt or whatever it's all just like
workout pants yeah all the time what
happened with
work like in the last year was work did
work go on a huge pause
for a while i mean you know
funny enough for me
yes and no i guess if you think about
the entertainment industry that was
you know um that took a pause for sure
uh during the pandemic but uh you know
right when
the pandemic started i uh
my son was born in february
right before the pandemic really hit so
i guess a year ago in march my
uh was when the pandemic really hit my
son was born in february
two months later i was doing a book tour
in april
a month after the pandemic hit
everything got crazy every we pivoted
everything it was all online stuff like
this so i'm like
taking care of you my newborn and we
also have a toddler and uh
everything with the pandemic and then my
last book you and i as mothers had come
out so i was doing a virtual
book tour for that so that was pretty
crazy
and then after that you know i just
released my my culinary line
prep on kitchen so then it was all prep
for that release
and um so during the pandemic
i was juggling my newborn my toddler
going to work at home and this kind of
work
but the entertainment industry yeah was
totally
nobody was on sets everything was shut
down just like
just like everybody you know but um i
was doing a lot of stuff like this
though like the book tour and all the
prep for my
my product line launched and stuff so it
was and having a brand new baby it was
crazy it was absolutely insane like the
first six months
were just a complete blur you might have
actually gotten more done
because of the format like you probably
didn't even have
more interviews spent more time i mean
having more time with my kids yeah and
my husband during that time was so
special yeah that silver lining
what was uh what was something that you
got to do other than that that you had
always wanted to do
that you had time for well honestly i i
think it was being able to have that
time because when i had my daughter i
went back to work
after oh my gosh it feels like forever
ago but like
six weeks or something like it was crazy
i was back on orange as the new black
and directing and doing yeah yeah
indirect and directing
um but yeah i mean being able to have
this concentrated time with my family
in this time that's so special when i
mean there's always so many wonderful
phases of course of your kids growing up
but having that
that first like incubation time when
they're like just
born and you guys are all bonding as a
family it's so special and there was
something
oddly like with the world shut down
around us
and having this bonding time together it
was very surreal
it was very surreal and there's also all
this fear because none of us know what
what's going on with this thing you know
and the fear of being a new mother and
you know um you know i i've never been a
mother of two before obviously so i was
just like it was my first time having
a second baby and all this like so there
was a lot of new
um it was crazy danica
but i i honestly think that that um
that time being able to really have with
the family was so
so priceless there was a way to look at
the whole situation and take the
positives from it
or i think there are other people that
more that melted down
and you know it was an opportunity for
one or the other
um but you know you talk about time with
your kids and
there's so much evidence uh to show that
their subconscious
is programmed for the basically like the
last trimester through the first
about you know maybe six or so years of
their life
so to be able to spend that critical
young
time where you think i feel like i feel
like i would have said i don't have kids
but
like oh they're they're two they they
won't remember this
but the weird thing is is that it's like
a deeper imprint than something that
comes and goes when you're like
24. oh my god yes
and so you know i've been so fascinated
to hear about your
your childhood and what your mom was
like and
your dad was a doctor and like
plethora of spreads at midnight that
your mom made
and like you had a really unique
childhood and i know that that's part of
what you wrote about
in your book um but i mean can you
can you can do you have perspective now
of kind of what that was like and the
good that you were able to extract from
it and then also the things that
maybe needed some reprogramming
or new perception for sure yeah i mean
i definitely had an unconventional
upbringing for sure
um you know youngest of five kids
growing up in jersey yes my father was a
doctor and
my mom was this very eccentric uh
chef um which is a huge part of why i
cook i mean she inspired me so much in
the kitchen
and you know watching her you know
working on her
tart flambe at two o'clock in the
morning and i'm like following her
around the kitchen because that's the
only time i could hang out with her
because she was not
your typical mom you know what i mean
like i've never been told to do my
homework i've never
been given a rule in my life and and i
think because of that
i i was like really responsible kid
because i had nothing to rebel against
like all my friends were rebelling and
doing all this stuff because their
parents were so many rules on them and i
was like
i i don't have anything to rebellion
says my mom was just
you know a very eccentric person and my
father
had the most amount of cases in two
hospitals which is like unheard of so
all he did was work
but yeah my mom was a huge influence on
me in the kitchen
and you know it's interesting because
you know you asked have i been able to
kind of
reflect on it or what's my viewpoint of
it now the thing that's
really interesting is until i had
kids i had never fully
dissected my upbringing you know what i
mean
um well really looked at it like i i
have so many justifications of things
that were like
not okay growing up just like period
like not cool and i'm also not the type
of person who blames i'm just like i
always try to look at
okay so how did i help cause this and
what can i
take from this so this doesn't happen
again that's so responsible
well i try i mean i try um and
i think because i was on my own at such
a young age like i left my house when i
was 15 and i've been on my own since
then but
wow when i had kids especially my
first child being a girl when i first
had my daughter it was
you know i was i had crazy postpartum
anxiety
first of all didn't even know what that
was because when you
i didn't know anything about motherhood
so when i you know the only thing that i
basically heard about postpartum
anything was like you always hear about
postpartum depression because that's
like
in the you know that's uh in the
verbiage of
things that mothers can suffer from and
i didn't have any of that you know what
i mean but i had this
this overwhelming anxiety
to protect this baby and
you know i was living in the lower east
side and
anytime like a siren would go up the
street i would be i would think that i
couldn't protect her i would think it
was like
an attack on my family i was having
panic attacks and all this stuff
and that is not my personality like that
is so
i really do pride myself on being like
the rock of gibraltar i really do like
that's why i love directing i love
having
a ton of responsibility and pressure
pressure and stress
and i'm like i i tend to do pretty well
in those kinds of environments like
super high pressure type stuff
i um and and i think that is one of the
reasons why i love directing it's one of
the reasons why i love high stakes poker
and i used to be like obsessed with poke
and all this like you know
i mean with with your career you must be
the same way
well i seek out discomfort i've found
that since i retired
i didn't feel like i used to be very
adventurous and then since i've retired
now i've like
jumped out of helicopters gone bungee
jumping you know i learned how to ski
and snowboard
and wake surf and like things that i
wouldn't have otherwise done so i
and or saying yes to interviews or
people or situations
and i realize that what i really like to
do is i really like to put myself in an
uncomfortable situation
to push sort of the threshold and widen
it like i like to get into that like oh
god should i do this can i do this
to prove to myself that i can i don't
know if that you can relate to that but
i just like to be uncomfortable
i can absolutely relate to that and i
used to put myself in situations like
that as well i totally get it
and to a point where i was like
you know when i was about to have my my
first kid i was out with a friend of
mine who was fully fully like
about to have her baby and i was still
like only halfway through
um like pregnancy and i'm like what is
the hardest thing like what should i
look out for because no one talks about
the stuff that's really hard
and she was like oh no she just at her
baby she just had her baby
and she was like it's it feels like your
heart
is outside of your body and you're
trying to make sure that nothing
hurts this thing and she's like and it's
just like your heart is outside walking
around your body
and she's like it's the most stressful
thing you'll ever experience and i'm
like
i'm okay with stress like i think i'm
gonna be okay no
no the universe was like laura let me
just show you
exactly for all the reasons we just said
like we put ourselves in these
uncomfortable situations and all this
stuff yeah nothing
prepared me for here
giving birth hearing that first squawk
of my daughter just
ripped through my entire being and i
woke up
at like a mother like i i everything you
could possibly imagine like i i
like in that moment like i woke up and
something inside of me woke up and and i
was so scared that i couldn't protect
her
and so in those moments you innately go
back to what you know
so i innately would fall back on okay so
how i was raised so it was go back to
work
right exactly it was the first time i
i like looked at how my mother raised me
you know what i mean because in that
moment of like anxiety
you know what you're doing you go right
to what you know it's like um you know
professional athletes and you know you
could speak to some cars and everything
which by the way is incredible
um i watched you all the time when i
lived in england racing
on that 70s show i mean i was so
grateful there was a cool show on
because there's in england i'm sure
you've probably spent time there doing
something yeah yeah yeah
there's not a lot of channels and i was
like oh my god i'm so grateful there's
like a cool show
i've been a fan for a long time we
actually i think we met very briefly
like
literally 20 years ago because i went to
a race
i did this race and you were there
and of course you i mean you were i
think
one of the only yeah female uh race card
at the time you were just
paved the way for it unbelievable what
you did
um and i remember meeting you then and
being like oh my god this woman is just
a complete badass
takes one to no one maybe thank you
but um but i do remember that that
experience of being at a race and
singing there and it was very inspiring
and you were just
so thank you oh god um it's interesting
so when i looked back at how i was
raised uh
it was the first time i was like wow
that's actually
some of that stuff is not cool some of
that stuff is i hear you
not okay and it was the first time i
really had to
come face to face with that so in terms
of what you're asking
of you know kind of my viewpoint on it
now is
i like to look at it and say okay great
i can now
choose what i'm going to pass on to my
kids and what to leave behind that's our
responsibility
and um and and i gotta tell you it's
been a rude awakening
of things that i had justified for so
long about how i was raised that just
got holes completely poked in them
because um
and having to really look at that oh my
gosh it's been
it's been like a reckoning i'm not gonna
lie
it's been like a reckoning and and i
wrote about it in my
in my last book i had to because how
you're mothered and by the way whoever
you identify as that person in your life
whoever is that person
who has that role in your life um
affects you like how could it not
whether if you have a relationship
or a lack of not having that
relationship
can impinge just as much as having the
relationship
so it's been really really crazy i'm not
i'm not gonna lie having to look at that
has been really really hard
and that's why i felt i i needed to
write about it to like
comprehend it for myself yeah and i
think that the
the aspect too of just sharing and
um you know planting seeds with other
people of like hmm
wait that pattern keeps showing up maybe
like i mean i spent a lot of my life
thinking it was never my fault right
like
and then you end up realizing that it's
your perception on the situation it's
your patterning it's your you know the
the kind of
relationships or dynamics that you
attract to show you your healing
because like you need that other per
other person or other child
a child or something to reflect
something back to you and it's such a
journey i mean to
to unpack the the childhood programming
is is really deep deep deep work i mean
i've had
i mean i've i've had therapists i've for
a while had two therapists
and you know there's a there's a lot of
reflecting that needs to happen to get
to the bottom of it and
i don't know about you but all of my
sort of reckoning
um as you said or breakdowns to
breakthroughs
felt like i mean they felt nuclear like
i would be like
sobbing like uncontrollably going what
is it where is this coming from
right right and then you come out the
other side and
you know there's so much lightness to it
and i always tell people that are
if once you've started to once you
started to like dive into
childhood trauma or patterning
like you're so much of the way there
already because most people never do
yeah but you know it's so funny with
what you're talking about where it's
like
i'll have periods of time where i'm like
still
like i'm still talking about my
relationship with my mom like even now
it still affects me this deeply
yeah isn't that crazy and it's like but
it's true
you know what i mean it's um it's so
deep in there and we're just like trying
to get to it and figure it out but i i
really do have times where i'm just like
really still
like at this point in my life i'm still
like affected by
you know my whatever with my mom but
our parents have such a huge impact on
our
everything um it's crazy
it's crazy and now as a mom i'm like
whoa this is a big
it's big big responsibility you're
responsible for their
for their attachment style for their
sort of trauma orientation as they
because you're gonna they're gonna
happen because i don't want them
but what um like what were the things
that you
uh that you say when like not okay
what were those things that were not
okay that you're like look moving
forward
with love these things are not the
patterns that i'm gonna continue with my
kids
yeah i mean you know
again now now that i look back on it
it's um
being that we did have such an
unconventional upbringing
and while that kind of um
freewheeling lifestyle i tended to do
pretty well
in and i think it's another reason why
when i was 15 and i was you know gonna
move to a foreign country and
and work by myself my mom was like okay
go would i ever let my 15 year old
daughter
do that no like i literally she dropped
me off at the airport and i had a
name this is granted this was in 1995 so
things were very different than
we didn't have cell phones when she
dropped me off the airport i had the
a scrap of paper with a man's number
written on it we didn't know who this
guy was or someone i was supposed to
call when i got to italy oh my god
and she's like all right love you and
like drives off
you know but but back then it's like
she she was always kind of this an
eccentric artist as well so i think just
the idea of me going and working in
italy she was like go and i think there
was a part of her that knew i'd be okay
but even still looking back like i would
never
um let my kids do that but i think
a lot of the hands-off parenting
of never talking to her kids about
anything
um that we would be going through as
children and oh sure
being emotional being emotional yes
being held that way
yes and being a kid it sucks it's
like so hard it's hard enough just being
a person
and being a kid having to learn all this
stuff oh my god like
you know it's just you know now
it's like i can reflect on stuff you're
like okay cool so
i know that what that person's doing
i've worked with enough people in my
career to know like okay that person
stay away from that person don't work
with them you know what i mean like
as a kid you're just there's so much to
learn and it's so awful
um and and you're learning all the stuff
you're like social
peer groups and this and that whatever
and puberty and growing up and like
my kids aren't there yet but they will
be and i'm gonna talk to my kids about
all of it um so not having that
and having her be and my dad be totally
kind of absent
that that's something that i don't want
to bring to my kids
um she also taught us some you know
dysfunctional things with eating
like you know she grew up in a time of
like twiggy
you know what i mean she grew up in a
time where like yeah
you know exactly you know what i mean um
but
her version of kate moss which is you
know this little
twiggy toothpick model
and you know beauty and image was always
um she looked at it as survival
wow beauty and weight and being
thin and what you look like on the
outside was i mean she literally looked
at it as a survival tool
and it's how she you know but the thing
that's interesting too is she's crazy
smart i mean she got into vassar which
back then
vasser was very very well regarded and
it still is oh yeah
but even when she was growing up when
she went to college it was very very
well regarded
she was ambassador she was an art
history major she was a teacher when she
met my father
but her whole thing was she wanted to be
a doctor's wife she wanted people to
she grew up with nothing she was poor
poor poor
like had no money my grandmother was a
nun in a convent
and ended up meeting someone and left
the convent and had her children and
literally was a rosie the riveter like
she worked for grumman
drilling rivets on airplanes so she
didn't have her mother either
like her mother exactly this is always a
lineage thing
so it totally is it totally is
so you know my grandmother put this
pressure on her like you need
you're not going to end up doing what
i'm doing you are going to
and back then you know the way
it was you know you meet your husband
you
get married you have children and you
you know that was that's what she
was raised with that's what was told her
and that's what she pushed onto us
and i don't agree i don't agree
i just don't agree so you've talked
about you've talked about how you didn't
even think about marriage like that
wasn't even
like for a while you didn't you weren't
even thinking about that marriage kids
right i had a very different path where
i was just like
i wanted to be completely
self-sufficient i wanted to have i never
wanted to rely on
anybody to be my you know
um because i saw what it did to her
you know i mean not having anything for
herself and always having
leaning on you know my father was the
breadwinner
and even as a youngster i was like i'm
always going to be self-sufficient and
be able to take care of myself
because i didn't i didn't agree with
that decision and i didn't and i and
but you you know again now that my
mother i had to really look back and be
like that was her upbringing that's what
she knew she did the best she could
but um and everything's so different i
mean when you look at our current
culture versus what
our parents grew up with i mean it's
it's
it's so many i mean the evolution is
massive
um so you have to look at that you don't
even have to look at what she was
influenced by and everything else
which helps me not go into a blame thing
it helps me get
empathy and understanding for her which
is what i want i always
want to try to understand why someone
does something yeah
um because so then i can make sense of
it you know and she taught us
really dysfunctional things with food
and weight and body and
a lot of a lot of really gnarly stuff
with body image
to four daughters by the way and you
were a model which like stack all those
sorts of things which
you and even if you just go into
modeling alone like i have a friend
who's a model
was a model and just the the the rules
and the
telling you to lose weight or look a
certain way just there's just like that
that in and of itself but then when you
stack on top of it the imprint
the the programming from a young age of
seeing certain things associating
certain things like
that i mean was there a come was there a
[ __ ] now to come down but come
out from that like how did you heal that
because that's
that's deep you know it's funny i didn't
even i literally fell into modeling i
did not um
i was not one of those kids who was like
i want a model i want to act
it just wasn't part of my experience
like i grew up in a small town in jersey
nobody is like nobody in my public
school in jersey was like acting or
modeling or anything like it just was
not i wanted to be a doctor
um but i got this opportunity my sister
my eldest sister uh she was working for
glamour in new york
because we lived only half an hour
outside of manhattan
and she always loved that glamorous
stuff
i was a total tomboy i wanted nothing to
do with it
and she's 10 years older than me so she
was working in new york and she was like
you should think about modeling so i was
always tall
but i was athletic you know um
and when she mentioned it i'm like that
is why would i ever want to do that
that's
it was literally like she's speaking a
different language i never had
aspirations to do anything like that
and my mom loved it
loved it and all of a sudden my mom like
took this interest
oh wow wow add another dynamic to it now
all of a sudden you get attention
for it like exactly exactly so this
woman who i literally don't know
anything about
who i only see when i'm following her
around the kitchen
um in the in the wee hours of the
morning when she's like
making her eccentric foods and stuff
turducken
peeking dog or whatever not even little
whatever
massive culinary experience she was
doing but i gotta say though
just sidebar her magic that she did in
the kitchen
i mean to this day i'm under the spell
like i love cooking i love how
it was shown to me as a child it was so
special and
it sounded like she was like this is how
you scramble an egg like her way of
cooking was so
um extreme that
you know for me the way that i even got
to where i am right now with her product
line was that
she would do all this phenomenal cooking
but she was never even there with us to
enjoy it
and because she was always cooking so
she would like serve it and go back in
like
holidays i don't have a single memory of
spending with my mother because she was
always in the kitchen
but she always loved to do the cooking
and everybody loved coming over because
margaery was cooking you know but
she was not she was never with us so one
of the main
reasons why i wanted to even you know do
my product line was like there's got to
be a way to
cook for your family and with your
family and for your friends and stuff
and be able to be present
and enjoy it because life is just too
quick like i see
time go i sorry i'm again in new york
you're gonna hear sirens
you know i see my kids grow i see time
and
literally in front of my eyes and i'm
like i don't want to miss this
i want to be able to cook and be with my
kids but also
be there and be present to like hear
about their day and hear what's going on
and
you know so that's where i differed from
her where i do different from her which
was my impetus for my whole point of
view
on cooking is to make it easier and more
streamlined so we can
be present what makes what makes the
line special like what are some of the
things where you're like
thank god for this because this makes
things easier this makes things faster
um because i get i love cooking too like
on a
sidebar myself i'm a huge lover of cook
cooking
oh i could be that person that's in the
kitchen that just like and i get real
really narrowly focused and a little
edgy because i'm like i don't even like
help because i'm like
i know i know what i'm making right
pretty much
most things don't have the exact same
timeline timeline from start to finish
so i can just start staggering i know
exactly how to do it
and i'm like i got it like nobody even
really can help me um but i love cooking
too so
tell me like how this would help me in
the kitchen i mean like as
example um i i designed this cutting
board because i would hate like i'm
you on my cutting board it gets
overflowed with you know food scraps and
i have to like
break my flow like you just said like
you're in the zone you're doing thing
and i would be like i'd have this tiny
piece of real estate left
on the corner of my cutting board where
i'm like chopping i'm like this is
ridiculous
and then you pick it up and you have to
lug it to the garbage and dump it and
come back and like start your flow again
and i'm like there's got to be a way to
make this more streamlined
because my friends that are pro chefs
are like you never want to break your
cooking flow and you always want a clean
cutting board
and that's how they're like super
efficient in their kitchens and i'm like
okay so i i designed this cutting board
with this arm that comes out and
comes up and holds a bag into place and
i just got my patent approved and
that's cool yeah so i'm thinking about
all the times that i cook brussels
sprouts or cut brussels sprouts and i'm
like
first off brussels sprouts are the most
annoying things to prepare
forever um but i'm thinking like of all
the all the little head
the ends of them and i'm like yes are
everywhere you know
yes i'm with it and that's why i was
like there's got to be an easier way so
that's a perfect example of
um you know and funny enough i have my
i didn't think we were going to talk
about this but this this is my little
official patent
oh cool that's so cool that probably
takes a while
oh wait let's see the picture what does
it look like
this is like because this is um
well let me show you a picture that
actually shows it
but basically i mean it's cool right
it's like
it shows the little oh wow so you just
scoop it off
just yeah with your knife just push it
off exactly just put it straight up into
a bag
and a biodegradable bag so that's like a
thing that i designed where i'm like
that will streamline our time in the
kitchen and that's just one of the
things
that's part of my line but um the point
being like i
i wanted to think of this stuff to make
our lives easier in the kitchen
and um but it did all spur from
again my upbringing it's so core it's so
in me
and um and it is one of those things
where
you know i my mom is such an amazing
influence but
and some of the things i won't pass on
but also
because that experience had such a deep
impact on me now
you know i created a whole line inspired
by my
culinary experience and how she
and how that you know affected me but um
but yeah i mean she was really excited
about that whole modeling thing
so i did it and um i did a model for
that long by the way
i only modeled for about a year and a
half and all of it was in europe
and my first you know as a model which i
did not like
it did not i'm like modeling i know
people have this idea of these models
and it's like this glamorous life
it's not tell us what it's really like
what's it really like
it's honestly it's like well first of
all models if you're not a working model
which not a lot of models are
it's hard to get work as a model and
first of all
back in 95 half of your um commission
was gone
like how an agent they took a 50
commission in italy in paris they took
60.
60 of your money was an agency also you
can say
also in france for sure for sure you're
like all right
there's a balance there but uh and it
was an amazing experience
but um but i didn't because i was like a
tomboy i didn't really get along with
other models and not get along but i
just didn't like the lifestyle i wasn't
you know like party promoters would come
scoop up all the models and bring them
out to clubs and i never did that stuff
i asked my mom to help me get my own
apartment
because i wasn't making money as a model
so um i
live on myself and you just pound the
pavement all day long you just pound the
pavement
and you you go to you know
they were called ghosies back then now
this is probably all different the
commissions and everything are probably
different now because this was in 95
but you just you get your list of
appointments you pound the pavement you
go one after the other you stand in
front of like bored
european people who like flip through a
book or like
whatever and then you're just kind of
like part of this cattle
system well you were around in the day
and age of like the models
right yeah i feel like that was when
modeling was still like you know
nowadays i mean look at victoria's
secret they don't even have their
i mean like like imagine i mean imagine
if you're a model and you think like
that's
you know i'm sure there's lots of sort
of creme de la creme but
being a victoria's secret model is like
a pretty cool thing to do that and be in
the show
right have those now well to touch on
that quickly i would
my generation of modeling was like the
end of like
the era of the mod like the real era of
the model was like
cindy crawford claudia shipper naomi
campbell l mcpherson like
those women and they were a little bit
older than iowa
they're you know back then they were
like the supermodels but they were a
generation
right above me you just missed out on
being in the george michael's music
videos
i i missed it um but my generation was
like karen nelson
was a huge model then kate moss was
still
uh a supermodel but this was you know in
in the mid 90s
is when i dabbled in it but i very
quickly
got this audition in in uh italy for an
italian uncle ben's rice commercial and
i booked it i don't know why but i
booked it and i loved this acting thing
because modeling
did not i didn't like it and it's hot
and you know it just wasn't my anything
about me just wasn't a good fit i did
this quick model this quick acting job
and i called my mom and i was like
there's something here like
there's something in this job that's
speaking to me i want to try this acting
thing
and again because my mom was so
wonderful in this way she was like great
come home
went home and she's like what do we have
to do
and i'm like well i have to learn how to
act and she
literally grabbed the yellow pages which
we don't have anymore
she grabbed the yellow pages opened it
up and she's like pick an acting teacher
so we literally just looked in manhattan
and
literally pointed at some random person
and we called them up and i took acting
classes with them for a little bit
and then within a year i booked i got an
audition for that 70s show
and i booked it that went so fast how
were you when you booked that 70s show
18. yeah so i lived in europe for about
a year and a half
came back started learning how to act
and about a year later when i was
just turning 18 in 1998
i booked that 70s show and i moved my
entire life to la and i'm like
they speak english here that's fine like
i don't know
you know because i learned enough
italian to get by and i absolutely loved
the culture i love it love it um but
still like moving to l.a versus moving
to
italy or whatever i was like okay i can
i speak the language here this will be
easier for me i always i so i moved to
i moved to england when i was 16. like
we've had similar i could i really yeah
yeah i see me and you in lots of ways
and um
which is cool because like i look at you
and think you're so strong
you're so determined you're so
accomplished and
so confident like you just just for me
you feel
so strong that's the best word i can say
the feeling is mutual i moved there when
i was 16
and um that was such an experience i
feel like i grew so much in life from
moving to england when i was 16. but it
is
but it is it is a gamble and you do grow
up really fast so
maybe it's not that shocking i mean you
know
my life moved pretty quick and you know
yours definitely did to go
move on but there's there's always
little catches like i feel like
we have to go through every phase of
what life
tends to give to us right there's got to
be you gotta have the childhood you need
to have like the party phase you need to
have
like i feel like all the phases kind of
have to happen
and since everything right moved and it
doesn't mean they go in order like look
at michael jackson things just didn't go
in order
so you know was there a phase
by moving so fast from you know uh
so much freedom as a and childhood to
moving to italy to moving to l.a
modeling acting bam and all of a sudden
you're huge
that 70s show was such a popular show
and was obviously everywhere because i
lived in
england right right was there a phase in
there that you're like
you skipped over that you visited later
on in life and you're like oh this is a
little out of order but
yeah no i know exactly what you're
saying um i
you know i went through some phases
actually before
i even ended up on that 70s show um
and you know so i i've had
all all the phases just like you know
just like you're talking about
i may be a little bit out of order
because i
i feel like a cat sometimes where i've
had like nine lives
of like i look back at my life i have
like this period of time
before i started that 70 show and that
was like one life and then once i got on
that 70 show that was like
another life and then that ended which
was such an era you know
in my life it's 70 shows eight years and
then i you know moved on from that into
like
you kind of like graduate to other stuff
in your life
it's just um i've had these like
specific
periods of time and now being a mother
this is like a whole new
life of like being a wife and a mother
um
and also juggling your career you know
because i'm a working mom so it's like
it's i've had these like so many lives
happen
nothing i did was like your typical
and sounds like same with you you know
you go to school you graduate you go to
college
you graduate you get a job
and then you're just like in the thing
and we kind of did it
a completely different way um
so yes i've definitely had all the
phases and they
they are pretty out of order but when i
look back
there's definite what i will say is i'm
so glad i went through
the phases i went through at the time i
went through them because you know
there's certain things where i'm like
okay glad that happened
before i was you know like uh you know
whatever
whatever it was like experimenting with
whatever or
um you know i don't know any of the
stupid things that kids do
um with like alcohol or whatever dumb
stuff
that we all do it's like you know
i definitely because i had such a free
upbringing
in so far as like rules um i had a lot
of freedom
um i definitely like did a lot of stuff
as a youngster
that i would be really bummed out if i
knew my kids were dealing
you know that is kind of a bummer that
you know you i want to be able to like
talk to them and i
i didn't have that but i had a lot of
other
great stuff you know i had the trust for
her to let me go
and the trust would be like what do we
have to do to you know when i was like
learn how to act and she was supportive
of all that like i would never be where
i am without my mom
um my dad passed away when i was young
which is why i keep referring to my mom
and my dad
is your mom still alive she is she is
she has
um she's had pretty bad
um dementia for a while so
it's kind of nearing the phase of like
there's really nothing more the doctors
can do it's just like
we just have to kind of manage it with
you know
good food and whatever medication we can
but um but you know i'm gonna go see her
on
you know saturday i'm gonna go see her
and bring my kids to see her and
i don't think she will remember my kids
but
but it's fun like we're just trying to
enjoy the time that we have and stay
present
you know but um but it's interesting
because
because my mother will never have that
because she's had it for
a while now and we'll you know we'll
never have that like end of the scene in
the movie where it's like
the cathartic you know moment of like
why couldn't it have been like this or
like talk to me about this like
why did this happen and you know we'll
never have that and that's another thing
i've really had to kind of kind of terms
with too
like that's okay we're never gonna have
that conversation
um it's not life is not a movie
you know what i mean you're not gonna
have that third act monologue of like
this is what happened you know what i
mean whatever but
it's it's interesting but um but yeah i
mean
to answer your question i went through a
lot of phases just like we all do
just like we all do and uh really happy
to be exactly where i am
right now talking to you thank you what
do you do what do you do to ground
i mean i know you say you love cooking i
mean i know you love cooking and i know
that's something that you've said you do
to relax but
is there anything outside of that that
you that you've developed over time
where you're like these things
really helped me to feel like i
re-baseline or reorient or feel
grounded and can then sort of take on
the world again
yeah i mean i'm i'm a really physical
person so i do really well
when i'm active so if i'm having a
really
tough day like struggling with um
because that you know
this last year and a half has been so
hard on
all of everybody no matter where you are
in your life it has been
tac like taxing that's a silly word it's
been like
you had to really deal with yourself you
know what i mean there's no distractions
it's like you're locked down you're you
know
in it and you're really having to look
at yourself and your life
and what this all means and also it's
emphasized in relationships so and
yeah that's why they either failed yes
or they
grew exactly exactly totally
um so for me i really especially this
year i really realized that i need to be
physical i need to be active and i feel
like that
really helps my my head space so
if i'm like having an overwhelming day
or whatever it is or i'm really worried
about my kids or
whatever because i worry about my kids a
lot that's like something i'm always
trying to
quell that's normal i i mean like and
that's like that's the way you're
programmed i just did an interview with
a guy named jordan peterson
he's canadian he um he's a
theolo he's like he talks about theology
and psycho
he's a psychologist as well he's a
really interesting guy but one of the
things that he
uh he wrote the 12 rules for life book
but one of the things he said is that
when a woman
hits puberty she all the sudden becomes
heightened to
to anxiety she's much more predisposed
to the anxiety because she's now
entering into fertile years
and part of the role of the mother is to
be on high alert so women have a much
higher chance of having anxiety because
you are the one that cares for the child
you are the primary i mean i know that
there's a father but
you know you're for a while you are the
only one when you're pregnant
and so a woman a woman once they hit
puberty
and he said it never goes away he said
once they hit puberty they're more
more they have more anxiety and then of
course when you become a mother
it's even more because it's your role
that is it's like a it's a primal um
baseline sort of feeling so you're not
wrong this is a normal thing
yeah i mean it's i mean i look
i my son is just over a year old now
and um it was definitely easier with him
having gone through it with
with my daughter but you know when i do
when i talk to my
friends who are mothers and and their
partners as well
um it does get better
and and it's even gotten better for me
already
um it definitely gets better but my kids
are so young and i'm still such a new
mom
that yeah the worry is like overwhelming
it's overwhelming so i do what i can
and again like like we touched on
earlier i
that wasn't my personality before like i
didn't even know
that that was part of my makeup and i
didn't have kids until i was 36
um that's when i had my daughter but
because i focused on my career and i
wanted and i i felt for me
everybody's different but for me it was
important that i wanted to have
kids with my partner that was very
important to me
um and i wanted to wait you know until
i found my partner and you know thank
goodness
it happened but um but you know
in terms of negotiating that kind of
anxiety which i haven't really
dealt with i've dealt with regular life
anxiety of like work stress and you know
whatever like family stress like we
always have a lot of family drama
um uh you know we're irish catholic and
half
russian jewish and there's like a lot of
a lot of like you know
um it was just my family is
outrageous yeah it's just like it's
outrageous
um so there's always like stress around
the family and whatever and blah blah
but it's funny it's always funny like
holidays with my family i mean now it's
different you know
now we have kids so we always have to
like be careful of that but
before we were all parents it was just a
comical
uh situation it was like home for the
holidays all the time like it was just
crazy
um even though i haven't seen that movie
for years so i don't know if that
reference still works i'm gonna say you
should probably make a movie about your
family yeah oh my gosh
it would be an amazing movie um what was
i talking
about um and that's the other thing too
after kids you start like forgetting
things
but being physical working out things
like spinning i have like a spit like in
my office and stuff like that that
really helps keep my my mind
kind of center that really helps a lot
things like
yoga i know that sounds like a
everyone's like yeah of course yoga but
really
whenever i do yoga i always feel a lot
better and i'm gonna start doing this
thing
um i don't know anything about it i just
heard about it called the alexander
technique have you heard of this
it's about like breathing so there's a
lot of stuff that i've really been like
studying recently about like
breath just like breathing like
did you really did you read the book
breathe yet no
i haven't either i brought it with me
i'm i'm like trying to get away from the
arizona heat right now so i brought some
books and that was one of them
is it all about breath and how that is i
mean your breath is everything
if you think about it yeah well i think
that's actually why yoga feels so good
if that that's what i've identified
recently as i'm like
you know because like pranayama
breathing kundalini breathing
right off breathing all these different
things right they
they really can i mean you can get
yourself high with them like their
breathing is incredibly powerful and
even if you just think if i'm stressed
if you just took
one deep breath you already feel better
like think about yoga you go
you know exactly exactly
you know what's funny is i was talking
to a friend of mine and he was talking
about smokers
and he's like you know that's why
smoking calms people down because yes of
course it's the chemicals but he's like
you're taking big diaphragm breaths
[Music]
oh my gosh yes like uh yeah that makes
perfect sense but anyway so i'm
i'm really learning more about breathing
and you know my husband's done
movies where he's portrayed navy seals
and guys in the military and
they always talk about breath they
always
always talk about breath and remaining
calm and
focused and any kind of um
studying any kind of you know athletes
it's a lot of
it's a lot of breath and remaining calm
and all that so
i i'm really my new thing is i'm
researching about breath
and i really try to find time to have
self-care and be active that's
that's really kind of how i i mean how
do you
you know mellow out and stay self-care
what do you do for self-care
yeah i i mean i think walks are really
helpful
yeah rocks are great yeah i think walks
are really helpful
not in the arizona heat not the arizona
i mean they'll do but they'll be short
yeah exactly
walks working out i feel like it's the
only time where my mind
it's not in my mind um actually just
shifts out of work mode and i'm all i'm
thinking about is the moves and the
timing and everything so
i feel like working out is a really
helpful break for my mind
um and then vacations and learning
i like to learn about cultures and i
like to learn about um people and that
that's why the show's been so fun for me
i was already
looking watching a million things on
youtube and listening to podcasts but
now i just have more reasons and
it's so cool like how how
much you learn interviewing people you
seem like the kind of person that
uh is kind of always you know open to
new opportunities and
new levels of growth and getting into
that on
uncomfortable positions so is there
anything that
is kind of in the back of your mind or
the front that's you're calling in that
you think
maybe this is the next phase yeah i mean
i've
look i've studied a lot of different
things
um you know even in my first book i
talked i was really really deep into
like chinese meridian theory
and metaphysics i mean i i i am too
yeah like i am always trying to learn
about
um a just trying to be a better
mother first now it's like how can i be
a more present like
the best mom i can be for these two
incredible kids and then the best
partner
i'm always looking and reading and
checking under every rock about just how
to be a better just person and and um
and be be more present and
because it's so everything moves so
quickly i can't believe the pandemics
already been happening for like a year
and a half i mean
it's crazy so for me you know
i've done many different things i've
studied many different
religions and philosophies and and um
and i'm always
searching and right now where i'm at in
my life with my kids and
currently is i'm really trying to stay
focused
and the the breathing thing is something
i'm going to start kind of researching
really in a real way next i'm going to
start
you know looking into that um
maybe i should read this book breathe
and uh someone tell me about this
alexander technique thing
i'll look into that next because i think
that'll really help with the worry of my
kids and stuff
i also meditate i try to meditate every
day
um my husband and i like to meditate
together
um so that that's actually helped a lot
and what's funny is my last book you and
i's mothers
um i because i'm a new and at that time
i only had my daughter so i
i wanted to talk to many different women
of different backgrounds ethnicities
um culture you know just to get
different viewpoints on motherhood
because the whole book
you know is about motherhood and i
wanted to learn
from these women like what i
found that across the subject of
motherhood there's different there's
like common denominators of things that
we
kind of deal with and i wanted to touch
on those whether it was like
you know relationships
hormones and stress um feeding ourselves
and our family
um community and i would talk to all
these wonderful women
and get their viewpoint on motherhood so
i could share it with my readers
and a common denominator um
through just talking to all these
wonderful women was most of them
meditate
and i was already meditating um
and my husband actually grew up in a tm
a lot of people do tm like you hear
about like oprah and seinfeld knowledge
people in cm
he actually grew up in a tm community in
iowa
when he was a kid he left very very
young in
iowa yeah in iowa yeah it wasn't even
like mount shasta or no i know
in iowa there's like the mecca is in
iowa for
tm which is i know i know um
but he was already meditating and then i
learned and it's just
it's so great it's so grounding and the
thing that's
really interesting is um most of these
women who i talk to
who are all moms they all and like bad
ass women
um they all meditate and i was like okay
great so i'm already
you know on that path so that's great so
that's something i'm definitely going to
keep doing because it really helps a lot
and
especially when i'm directing you know
you're up before the sun comes up and
you're home
when the sun is down you have no time
for anything so i really try to do
a quick meditation in the morning before
i leave and then
i when i'm directing i never have lunch
breaks because you're always like
preparing for the next scene right after
everyone gets back
but i always try to take like even if
it's 10 minutes i try to find somewhere
to just
close my eyes when it's like center
myself and think about the day but um
but yeah i mean that i i would say like
getting into the breathing thing and
then just being able to meditate and
calm
calm myself for a second has really been
so so helpful
well i mean i'm excited to see what
comes from that because
what you're telling me is that you get
centered in yourself
and calm and non-reactive and right it
also i think opens you up into a more of
a flow state
where you're sort of noticing the signs
you're noticing
synchronicities you're noticing sort of
where the universe is pushing you and
pulling you
and holding you back and you know all of
those things and so
i have no doubt that it'll lead to
another amazing
natural thing for you to do as you
transition from modeling into acting
that you loved and then
into cooking in a cooking line and
sharing and writing
a book i mean it's really cool it's so
cool to talk to you you're a really
really fascinating strong person
so are you danica i wish we had another
hour to get into like
quantum physics and energy totally oh my
gosh that'd be awesome
all the things so maybe you can come
back on and we can dive into the quantum
field
i'd love that i love that thank you so
much for having me this was so much fun
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today
i hope you enjoyed it if you like what
you heard today and you want to hear
more please click on the subscribe
button